is getting massaged or something you
know in the beginning when we first
started this podcast like years ago he
would always say
ah you know what i love about kalila
is that after sex she would just like
roll over and not want affection and
she'd get on her phone that couldn't
have been farther from the truth no that
you're like that but baby you're so
[ __ ] like that
you're so [ __ ] like that i can't even
believe you're saying this out loud
right now telling the truth
baby you know what i was like that i
wanted to keep you so badly and this is
the one thing you said i don't cuddle i
don't like that stuff
and so i was like i want to stay in this
relationship i want him to like me so
much so i'm going to play the cool girl
and so after sex i would just be like
pretend and i'd be like oh that's what
you're doing i want to be held
i said it up front i go i don't like it
up front
right i never said like oh i'm a [ __ ]
cuddle master baby i got a [ __ ] of
three stripes on my black belt on that
[ __ ]
you know what i mean no i was like i
don't like it i'll do it for you
all right
and i'd do it for you
when
i have what eight
years you have thousands of times you
have never cuddled with me in eight
years are you out of your [ __ ] mind i
have it so many times you have never
never that's hardly huddled with me
after sex is it not that hard to believe
really
on the couch
after sex after school on my [ __ ] wow
on my doubts or everything yes
you have never cuddled with me after sex
because can i tell you why get back up
all right
because you don't know about korean
anatomy
okay and for us right
for you you guys
get your energy right from protein
correct
and carbohydrates
am i not right i love carbohydrates
koreans right
our energy is sheerly through our
testicles
and it's based on our [ __ ] our sperm
and we eat we use it to make life we
also use it for energy
right so when i come
right
i can't move it's a physiologic it's a
korean physique there we go korean
anatomy
right that's why i want to so badly
after i call my god i want to hug her
but i can't get to her it's the calm
because of the calm energy
see
[Music]
can you understand this do you empathize
now that makes you feel so much better
what
now that you explain thank you so much
become
yeah what is it about why do women want
to spend time with you all the time
we're at the barber shop now what is
this what is going on over here
hey men want to [ __ ] be held too i've
held many men on my bosom after sex you
want to be held
i know gilbert wants to be held i know
it i know it
shut up don't even play cool
i like my hair being played with uh-huh
okay okay worse no it's fantastic
shame this [ __ ] sensitive wonderful
being and also yeah i uh yeah i like the
hair i don't like the cuddling because
my arm when she